Okay…
This isn’t good.
I know you have no idea who I am, and have
no reason to care, but my lovely wife Brenda
and I got ourselves into kind of a sticky
situation here.
We just wanted to go shopping, gosh darn it,
and now we’re trapped in here!
I think there are monsters…
Oh god.
This is horrible, I’m so scared - Not just
for my life, but for hers.
And worst of all…
Why does it feel so oddly familiar?
Okay, okay.
Gotta keep a cool head.
How did all this begin?
It’d been about a year since the Incident.
We don’t like to talk about it much.
My psychiatrist tells me that, after I was
kidnapped by that mysterious international
criminal organization and kept in their clutches
for 100 days, it’s likely I repressed most
of the memories to avoid the trauma.
He told me it’s an extremely common reaction.
So common, in fact, that even Brenda can’t
fully remember the exact circumstances of
my kidnapping - Just her immense gratitude
when the FBI brought me home.
Eventually, we moved out of our old place
- too many dark spots - and into a new apartment,
in a different town, in a different state.
Things were good, until one day we realized:
We didn’t have a coffee table.
Who can live without a coffee table these
days?
So we decided to make our way to the local
Ikea to buy a TRULSTORP coffee table.
Brenda wouldn’t let me go alone.
She never lets me out of her sight anymore
since I was kidnapped.
Neither of us had been to Ikea in over a year,
so naturally, we found it easy to get lost
in there.
Those warehouses are confusing, after all.
But this time, it was different.
We were lost for hours on end.
We even started calling out for help, but
we never got any reply.
And when, after what must have been closing
time, the overhead lights shut off.
Well, we were less than calm about it…
As a day passed, the two of us stuck together.
We’d watched enough Scooby-Doo cartoons
in our youths to know that splitting up to
cover more ground is the quickest way to get
irreparably lost.
That being said, it’s not like sticking
together did us any better.
We kept wandering through the different departments,
wondering if we’d passed that LOMMARP cabinet
or that KOPPANG chest of drawers before.
We walked until our legs ached, trying to
stay strong for each other.
It’s impossible that we’d be trapped in
here.
Sure, I know these warehouses can be a little
overcomplicated, but this is ridiculous!
By the time the day ended - or at least, by
the time the store’s lights turned off - we
were able to find a SLATTUM queen-sized bed
to rest for the night.
Maybe we’ll be able to find a way out tomorrow…
How long have we been in here?
I check the date on my phone: 72 hours.
Though of course, there’s no internet or
cell service in here.
Naturally.
Brenda and I get up when the lights turn on
and start walking again.
Surely anyone who walks for long enough has
to find something, right?
We both hold this hope in our hearts as we
pass what feels like miles of cheap, flat-pack
display furniture, wondering what on earth
is going on.
Sometimes, we see figures moving in the distance.
Part of me can’t help but wonder if they’re
really there, or if I’m just losing my mind
in here.
Difficult to say.
It feels hyperbolic to even express this thought,
but there’s something oddly frightening
about the things I see out of the corner of
my eye.
I start to get the sense that we’re not
alone in this strange place, and frighteningly,
I don’t know if not being alone in here
is really such a good thing…
At least we have each other in here.
Oh god, oh god, oh god, things just got a
lot worse.
So Brenda and I were walking down one of the
many latticed aisles of the kitchenware department
when the lights shut off.
Thankfully, we’d picked up a pair of FRYELE
rechargeable flashlights, so moving in the
dark was no longer a dealbreaker for us.
Goody goody.
Or at least, that’s what I thought until
we encountered something horrific in there.
“Look!”
Brenda said, pointing into the distance.
“It’s a member of staff!”
I couldn’t tell you why, but the second
Brenda said that, a chill went down my spine.
It was like the lingering after-effects of
some memory I couldn’t recall.
There was a silhouette in the distance, and
in the beam of the flashlight, I could make
out the faint colors of an IKEA staff member’s
uniform.
I knew right then that it was time to get
the hell out of here.
But before I had a chance to say anything
to Brenda, the so-called “staff member”
had already closed the distance.
It ran into the beam of our flashlights, its
long, drooping arms and featureless face shining
in the light.
Instinctively, I threw myself into its path
to protect Brenda.
It forced me to the ground and began beating
me with its fists.
It kept repeating, in a kind of freakish,
robotic voice, “The store is now closed,
please exit the building.”
If Brenda hadn’t smashed it over the head
with a VATTENTÄT stainless steel kettle and
beat it to a pulp on the ground, I would have
been done for.
So now we know: There are monsters in here.
Great.
Food and water are becoming an issue.
It’s not something we’ve needed to address
until now because of the healthy supply of
snacks in Brenda’s purse, but there’s
a hard limit to things like that.
We realized we really needed to find food
in this place or we’d be doomed.
But after the encounter with that monster,
we’re moving cautiously.
Who knows how many of them are still out there?
We can’t travel at night anymore.
That’ll keep us safe, but it won’t do
anything about our hunger situation.
It’s only a matter of time.
Brenda’s a genius.
I don’t know how I’d ever survive in this
terrible place without her, I’d probably
die on day one on my own.
She remembered that no Ikea is complete without
a little mini cafeteria where they serve a
variety of Swedish dishes, including their
famous Ikea meatballs.
All we’d need to do, in the otherwise sterile
environment of the Ikea, is follow the smell
until we found our way to sweet, meaty salvation.
And that’s exactly what we did.
Eventually, this plan bore fruit and we found
our way to the cafeteria.
I’d never been so happy to see crappy furniture
store food!
We both grabbed a bowl full of meatballs when
suddenly, just before I could take a bite,
I felt an overwhelming wave of nausea.
Something about it felt so incredibly, unsettlingly
familiar.
What the hell was going on here?
Another day, another near-death experience.
Our hearts leaped up into our throats when
we turned a corner and saw one of those faceless
monsters just standing there in the next aisle.
We were ready to either square up or run for
the hills.
But oddly, this time, it didn’t even seem
to register our presence.
It was almost like, during the day, they didn’t
have the same aggressive nature to them.
Curioser and curioser.
Just like it said when it first attacked me,
I think these things really only do attack
when the store is closed.
Guess that makes them “Lawful Evil.”
God, I miss D&D…
We’re getting a little better at this whole
“freaky supernatural Ikea” thing.
Brenda figured, if there are monsters out
there, our best bet would be to arm up and
protect ourselves.
And hell, I’m not gonna disagree.
We scavenged different parts of the store
to make ourselves a mini Ikea armory: VÄRDEFULL
Meat Tenderizers, VÖRDA chef’s knives with
VÖRDA meat cleavers from the same set.
We also picked up some FRAKTA rope and tarpaulin,
and a pair of stylish VÄRLDENS travel backpacks
to carry all our new Ikea swag in, in addition
to the food we’ve been keeping in the Ikea
PRUTA Tupperware packs.
With the two of us together and all this equipment,
I feel like we’re ready for anything.
In the following week, we discovered that
we were not, in fact, ready for anything.
While what we would later call “The Eight
Days of Hell” started off rather pleasantly
- the standard wandering, foraging, and sleeping
- it ended in a no holds barred fight for
our lives when the lights turned off unexpectedly
while we were surrounded by maybe twenty members
of the demonic Ikea “staff.”
Even with our weaponry, we couldn’t fight
that many of them.
Instead, we ran for our lives in the dark.
That’s when Brenda tripped over a carelessly
discarded LILLABO three-piece toy train set.
I ran back to help her up, but they were already
too close for us to make it out of there.
Terrified, we hunkered down and waited to
die in each other’s arms.
That’s when a series of expertly-placed
gunshots rang out through the air, and the
staff members collapsed onto the ground, each
of their faceless heads perfectly perforated
by a well-aimed bullet.
We looked up to see the face of our savior:
A strange man holding a rifle and a bullet
proof vest, grinning wildly.
“Come with me if you want to live,” he
said.
And we did, so we did.
When we woke up the next morning after practically
passing out from the stress, Brenda and I
saw that we’d been shepherded into a miniature
makeshift campsite by our mysterious, well-armed
good samaritan.
He told us that his name was James, and he’d
been trapped in what he referred to as the
“Infinite Ikea” for weeks now.
Thankfully, he’d had his trusty rifle with
him, or he probably would have been killed
by the Staff long before now.
We decided, out of politeness, to not ask
him why he’d brought a rifle and a bulletproof
vest into Ikea in the first place.
We were just happy to be alive.
We even gave him a few of our tubs of meatballs
as thanks for the daring assist.
James told us there are others trapped in
here, some of which have even made full settlements.
With his weaponry and our supplies, we might
even have a good chance of finding others
out there, forming a group, and getting out.
And that sounded like a great idea to Brenda
and I, so we were more than happy to tag along.
Over the next 21 days, we explored more of
the “Infinite Ikea” with James.
It certainly felt safer with him around, being
able to take on the Staff at a distance rather
than risk being overpowered and killed in
a more traditional struggle.
James is a nice guy - If a little strange.
During our 21 day period of searching for
others, James killed a few different staff
members during the nights.
For Brenda and I, killing off attacking staff
members is a profound relief.
But James?
He seems to take an almost perverse pleasure
in killing them.
But we do what we can to overlook that fact.
At the end of the day, even if he’s a bit
of a freaky gun nut, he’s a valuable asset
in a world like this.
However, for days on end, our search for a
camp was fruitless.
There were supposedly a huge number of communities
inside the Infinite Ikea, which often have
their own unique cultures and hierarchies.
It was hard to believe that all of this was
actually happening.
Was James just making it all up and taking
us for a ride?
But even if he was just crazy, what other
options did that leave us?
We just had to keep going.
But nothing would prepare us for the kind
of madness we were about to face…
At some point during our journey, where we
were still searching for one of the supposed
outposts hidden in the depths of the Ikea,
we were ambushed - but not by the Staff.
No, it was a collection of human beings, wielding
knives and dressed in the Staff’s clothes,
wearing their hollowed out heads like masks.
There was maybe twenty of them when they got
the jump on us, surrounding us and neutralizing
any advantage James’ gun could have given
us.
These masked strangers identified themselves
as members of a nomadic gang calling themselves
“The Sons of Vardagan.”
They’d come from an outpost that had since
fallen, so at least we knew that James was
right when he told us about communities out
there in the Ikea.
And then something even stranger happened.
One of the Sons of Vardagan pointed at me
and said he recognized me.
I said that was impossible, and that I’d
never seen him before in my life.
He brandished his knife and started getting
in my face, claiming I was lying.
That’s when Brenda stepped forwards to defend
me, telling him to step off.
As wonderful as her intention was, this just
made things worse.
A few other members of the Sons of Vardagan
began ganging up on her, and that I simply
couldn’t abide.
Without even thinking, I threw an impulsive
punch, laying out one of the goons.
That turned all heads my way, and gave James
an opportunity to take his chance.
He turned his rifle towards some of them and
opened fire, killing several of them and scattering
the rest.
Maybe we were better at this whole survival
thing than we thought…
Over the next couple of weeks, we continued
our search, our confidence bolstered by our
win against the Sons of Vardagan.
We made occasional stops, searching out cafeterias
to refuel our meatball supply.
You need protein in the infinite Ikea.
At some point during the journey, James asked
Brenda and me a strange question:
“Have you ever heard of the SCP Foundation?”
While neither of us could answer that question,
there was a strange, faint memory of that
name.
Was it some kind of charity?
Maybe a government thing?
I don’t know, but something about it, just
like so many other elements of this impossible
situation, is eerily familiar to me.
I just don’t understand.
I just don’t get it.
And it frightens me.
68 days into our confinement, we found something
horrifying.
One of the camps that James had alluded to
earlier, or at least, what was left of it.
The walls were broken down and the courtyard
area of this makeshift community was littered
with corpses.
Brenda and I were horrified by the site of
what seemed like some kind of massacre.
James just strode forward into the camp, observing
the aftermath of some unknown carnage.
“Looks like we got here too late,” he
said.
“Shame.
Real shame.”
James advised us to collect any resources
worth taking from the ransacked camp and moving
on.
No point crying over people we never even
knew.
But looking at the bodies, part of me felt
as though I had known these people once, perhaps
in another life.
I got closer to one of these Deja vu-inducing
bodies, and noticed something strange: The
body had gunshot wounds…
Over the next four days, a nightmare erupted.
After discovering the massacre at the camp,
I came to realize that James couldn’t be
trusted.
He was dangerous and unstable, and I had every
reason to believe he was the one behind all
those killings.
I relayed these facts to Brenda and told her
that we need to get away from him as quickly
as possible.
But when we attempted to escape, he caught
us and held us at gunpoint.
He seemed intent on killing both of us.
He was bigger, stronger, and better-armed
than the two of us, so all I could do was
distract him and hope for an opportunity to
turn the tables.
I asked him who he really was, and why he
was here.
So, figuring he had nothing to lose, he told
us.
Once upon a time, he had been a Mobile Task
Force operative, a kind of special ops guy,
for that SCP Foundation group.
He’d been one of the best, but after he’d
horrendously botched a mission - including
intentionally murdering many civilians over
the course of his career, just for fun - he’d
been demoted to D-Class.
Which, to the best of my knowledge, seemed
to be human guinea pigs this SCP Foundation
used for cruel experimentation.
One of the experiments they used for him was
apparently this very location, the Infinite
Ikea.
He’d been in here for a long time now, with
guns and ammo he’d stolen from other Foundation
operatives that had been trapped in here.
In a sense, he loved it in here.
He got to do his favorite thing of all - killing
people - with nothing to stop him.
And now, he was going to do it to us.
I hugged Brenda tight.
I was sure that this would be our last moments.
James leveled the barrel of his rifle at us
and prepared to fire, when two figures emerged
from the darkness behind him, wielding knives
and hammers.
It was a woman and a large man.
They lunged at James and struck him, again
and again and again, until he collapsed to
the ground, bleeding, dying, gone.
These two people then looked up at me with
a sense of recognition and amazement.
And at that moment, I realized that I recognized
them too: They were Vicky and Barry.
I knew them.
I’d been here before.
Over the next several days, it all came back
to me.
The hundred days I’d spent in the Infinite
Ikea before - well, going on 200 days now
- The friends I’d made and lost.
The strength I’d gained.
I’d never been kidnapped - That had just
been a cover story formulated by the same
SCP Foundation that’d produced that gun-toting
maniac, James.
Brenda was amazed to hear all this, and I
was both amazed and delighted to see that
Vicky and Barry had survived.
We believed that Barry had died after leading
the Staff away from the encampment, but as
it turns out, some people are just too badass
to kill.
My memories were hitting me like a high-pressure
fire hose now, washing away the cobwebs and
giving me a kind of clarity that I hadn’t
known in an entire year.
And in that glorious moment, I remembered.
I’d gotten out of here before.
I could get us all out of here again.
The route was somewhere inside me.
I just needed to follow it.
Day 200.
I remembered somewhere, deep down, that I
needed to keep moving.
I led Brenda, Vicky, and Barry behind me.
They trusted me, and their trust would be
rewarded.
Step after step, hour after hour, until eventually…
We arrived.
Light filtered through the glass double doors.
A smile spread across my face.
Our breath quickened.
Barry began to tear up.
After all this time, we’d finally found
our way out.
We had officially survived 200 days in Ikea.
As we stepped closer, the automatic doors
opened, as though it was congratulating us.
We held hands and stepped out into the light
together.
Now go check out “How To Actually Beat SCP-3008
The Infinite Ikea” and “Surviving Inside
SCP-3008 The Infinite Ikea” for more adventures
from the scariest furniture store in the multiverse!